and I saw this interesting report it was
a survey called Personality and Social
Psychology Bulletin and basically they
found that liberals more than
conservatives base their opinions on
emotion this actually doesn't strike me
as hugely surprising but I thought it
was kind of interesting researchers
conducted six studies to examine
emotions ideology and how they act
together to affect support for policies
the first two studies focused on
intergroup empathy while the third study
examined the interactive influence of
ideology and despair on support for
policies are to spend self-identified as
being at different points of the
right-left ideological spectrum so after
they did this yeah it came out that
liberals are based more on empathy and
emotion than conservatives are pac-man
yeah big lefty liberal do you agree well
it's no surprise that the the policies I
mean just just look at what the policies
are right if you look at the strict
father morality of the right and how you
deserve to actually be forced to carry a
pregnancy to term if you were stupid
enough to get yourself pregnant aside
from whether you lacked the access to to
sex ed or birth control or whatever
that's a very unethical so so there's no
surprise whatsoever that empathy is
playing more of a role in that they
would argue that they're being
empathetic to the fetus right like that
they want they believe that that's life
so they're being actually empathetic and
that that's the argument they would make
but apply it to any other any other
situation I mean even if even if you
look at gay marriage right the idea is
the we should be we should be by law
discriminating against people because
they are if you have a religious
right-wing perspective living in a
situation that is sinful which is taking
an that's an unemployed right if they're
acting on the behalf of God it's a very
uninviting god who says it should be
punishment both legal and in the
afterlife for living this lifestyle that
they claim is sinful
so whichever whichever still whichever
issue you want to look at it as there's
no question I mean who could possibly be
surprised that empathy and progressive
politics are connected yeah do you think
there's some kind of risk though in your
political beliefs being so intertwined
with empathy I don't I don't know that I
have an example off the top of my head
but that you know especially in a time
when we live in this 24-hour news cycle
where we get information so quickly you
know you just see a video and everyone's
in the outrage machine so everything is
so based on emotion right every time we
see anything every one of media is
someone says something that you've never
heard of before and then they say time
you don't like it you start screaming
about it but there's there may be is
some risk in attaching empathy so much
to what you believe there's to I think
there's a confusion in the study sort of
tried to distinguish between these two
things and I don't know how well of a
job it did making decisions or taking
political stances on what policy should
be based on empathy is very different
than saying you're making decisions that
are emotional as opposed to empirically
based and we shouldn't confuse those two
things because we can look at the same
set of data right and say well I one
side based on empathy thinks this should
be the policy and another side based on
an equally accurate analysis of the data
without any empathy thinks the path
forward should be B that's different
than just saying I don't care what the
data are here the decision I'm making
based on emotion empathy and emotion are
two things that are connected but not
the same right what's that that famous
saying it's like if you're in your 20s
and you're not a liberal you have no
heart yeah and if you're in your 30s and
you're not a conservative you have no
brain so it sort of feels like it has a
little bit of that plank to it that
maybe younger people are a little more
emotionally driven and then that
naturally is gonna have you believe in
liberal principles then I don't know
what happens to people in their 30s when
they start getting more conservative
that's actually it doesn't happen that
that's one of the biggest myths
so let's see if I can explain this in a
way that's clear because even I have
trouble explaining this if you take a
survey at any given time and break the
results down based on age you will see
that the older groups are more
conservative than the younger groups
there is no evidence though that that
same younger group will in itself be
more conservative by the time they're
older what it is is that subsequent
younger groups end up being more liberal
so it's actually a myth that the same
people become more conservative as they
age it's that the oldest age group
surveyed at any given time is the most
conservative of those who are then alive
if that makes sense
yeah that's a little hard to wrap wrap
my brain around that but I do get you
you know it's interesting when when I
came out to my grandma she was in her
early 80s at the time she was always
very very liberal she was always you
know we too progressive stuff and eating
right and she was always sort of at of
her time but I remember when I told her
it meant nothing to her she could not
have cared less she said are you happy
and that was all that mattered to her
and yet there's this idea that somehow
older people like to her it was like I
think she had had for 80 some odd years
on the planet and what she had
ascertained at that point in life was
you just got to be happy right she
learned as opposed to you know somebody
that might be 80 that would be holding
on to some sort of religious belief or
something else that would supersede
happiness which I think the whole point
of living is is to find some peace of
happiness of course and if you just
think of yourself are you are you more
conservative now than you were 10 years
ago am i working no I mean well you know
we've talked a little bit about my
evolution where I don't think I'm as
purely progressive anymore as you are
but I am certainly as liberal I miss
staunchly liberal as I've always been
right so the comparison would be are you
more liberal or conservative at your
current age than your parents were when
they were your age and I think that's
the way to sort of illustrate it ah
that's interesting so the answer in that
case we'd definitely be yes because
obviously for gay marriage I would guess
my parents when they were my age were
although you could argue it just wasn't
part of the national discussion and
chubby had it been maybe they would have
but direct so I get that that's
interesting yeah I think that's a good
way to think about it
alright cool well what do you guys think
do you get more conservative with age or
is that just the complete misnomer and
our liberals were driven by empathy and
emotion that conservatives there's a lot
here of course we have a link to the
study in the description right down
below and let us know your thoughts in
the comments we want to be reading